i'd love to take this opportunity to
show you around
with moon knight we're in a very
different world
the world building is so complete and
interesting and it's hard to paint such
a big canvas while you watch the show
you will learn about ancient egypt
what was challenging is to do something
that has a historical feeling to stay in
the world of ancient egypt
we get to see these inner sanctums of
ancient temples
all brought to life by muhammad diab an
egyptian filmmaker who came in and
really had a point of view with the
story i put my heart and soul into this
series i loved basing everything on real
egyptian mythology
[Music]
all the names and roles of the gods it
has so much historical accuracy we did
research on how a tomb would look how
sarcophagus would look every single
texture and every single thing was so
authentic that's resonant through the
entire series as an actor it really
keeps you in the world
amazing thought has gone into creating
this show and i think it infuses
everybody with wanting to bring their
best
[Music]
you